madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal une large page spéciale emmenée
par claude sérillon sera consacrée à la
situation au proche orient
la tension reste extrêmement vive la
ville de jérusalem pour ce vendredi de
prières sous très haute sécurité un
calme relatif malgré tout dans les
territoires après quinze jours de
violences extrêmes
l'espoir d'un sommet au caire peut être
pour dimanche qu envisage avec optimisme
kofi annan reste qu'israël n'a pas donné
sa réponse sur place nos envoyés
spéciaux reportages analyses et
commentaires autour de claude sérillon à
jérusalem avec différents invités
le prix nobel de la paix attribué au
président sud coréen kim dae djoum pour
ses tentatives de réconciliation entre
les deux corées un artisan de la paix
reconnu par le comité norvégien
l'exclusion attendue du rpr de jean
tiberi mais le maire de paris n'a pas
dit son dernier mot
il est l'invité de ce journal mais
d'abord l'actualité au proche orient
avec eux donc cette page spéciale de la
rédaction de france 2 et nous retrouvons
tout c'est en direct de jérusalem claude
sérillon en arrivant cette nuit et
toutes les équipes de france 2 pour
préparer cette page spéciale on pouvait
craindre le pire aux une sorte de
lendemain du drame après tous les actes
de guerre d'hier
heureusement il n'en fut rien même s'il
faut déplorer une série de violences et
d'accrochages il y a eu un mort à hébron
après des incidents entre l'armée
israélienne et puis des lanceurs de
pierres et des jeunes qui ont attaqué
l'armée un mort un jeune palestinien de
22 ans à hébron et plusieurs blessés au
total 50 à 60 blessés pour cette journée
relativement plus tranquille que les
autres bien sûr après les événements
d'hier
on pouvait aussi craindre le pire après
les lynchages de militaires israéliens
ramallah après les riposte de l'armée
isrélienne aujourd'hui à or akiva c'est
non loin de tel aviv
les obsèques de l'un des militaires
israéliens lyncher ont été organisées
obsèques de ce militaire qui était un
jeune homme qui venait juste de se
marier qui est un jeune d'origine russe
en somme
l'impression ici et charles enderlin
notre correspondant permanent le disais
tout à l'heure
l'impression que nous sommes sur le pied
de guerre mais il ya quand même beaucoup
de discussions et les invités que nous
recevrons en direct au cours de cette
page spéciale à savoir cède erec acquis
et négociateur palestinien
monsieur avi pazner ancien ambassadeur
de france qui le porte parole d août
barack et puis monsieur miguel moratinos
qui au nom de l'union européenne tente
de recoller les morceaux qui sont trois
personnages clés pour la situation
aujourd'hui nous diront ce qu'il en est
de ce discussion éventuelle
merci que nous retrouvons dans un
instant dans la ville sainte pour cette
journée du vendredi l'esplanade des
mosquées ostensiblement encadrés par les
forces de l'ordre israéliennes a été
fermé pour la prière du vendredi aux
musulmans palestiniens
ceci afin d'éviter tout risque
d'affrontement risque d'ailleurs
inévitable se sont déplacés vers la
porte de damas comme en témoigne ce
reportage de claude sang permet sorte
heureusement aucune victime ni blessé à
déplorer ce matin l'ambiance était très
tendue entre la population arabe et les
policiers israéliens l'entrée de la
vieille ville
notamment ici à la porte de damas seuls
les hommes âgés de plus de 45 ans
étaient autorisés à entrer
la police ne veux pas décider
laissez-moi entré cinq minutes n'ont
même pas une minute
tout le monde est prié d'ouvrir son sac
et la fouille être esprits sortez tout
sortait tout même le tapis de prière
sera examiné attentivement et personne
n'échappe aux contrôles monsieur
monsieur arrêtez vous même crié pas
dessus comme ça on vous a dit stop
alors stop la tension monte
toi tu t'en vas toi si tu rentres chez
toi allez allez partez et dès qu'un
attroupement se forme
la police intervient à cheval après le
lynchage de ramallah et les
bombardements israéliens
les forces de l'ordre veulent éviter
tout affrontement notamment ici au mur
des lamentations lieu saint du judaïsme
qui se trouve juste en dessous de
l'esplanade des mosquées troisième lieu
saint de l'islam
ainsi toutes les portes d'accès entre
les deux lieux sont très sévèrement
garde
12 heures la prière commence l'esplanade
est quasi déserte et la mosquée d'el
aqsa remontés vis la prière se termine
aucun incident déçu une cinquantaine de
jeunes palestiniens se regroupent alors
devant la porte de damas les slogans
sont bien rodés vive arafat il faut
brûler tel aviv
les soldats restent très calmes et
répondre toute provocation dans cette
guerre qui ne dit pas son nom
chaque image kong alors les manifestants
mettent au premier plan des enfants
presque des bébés et comme la surenchère
n'a pas dit pourquoi ne pas leur mettre
une cagoule ont plus
c'était jour de prières aujourd'hui
chaque image comptait et à présent nous
retrouvons oncle de cérillan dans le
quartier ultra orthodoxe de jérusalem a
à mes achats rim
nous sommes dans mea sharim quel
contraste entre les images de guerre que
nous diffusons dans nos éditions depuis
plusieurs jours
et puis cette situation de quasi
festivités religieuses car c'est souccot
aujourd'hui en israël scop c'est la fête
des cabanes qui rappelle l'exode des
juifs sortant d'égypte et construisant
des cabanes qu'on s'y réfugier et donc
qu'on vient chercher quatre essences
d'arbres mire sol ses draps et palm pour
reconstituer une partie de ces cabanes
mais c'est aussi une fête qui célèbre la
responsabilité réciproque entre les
hommes
tout un programme compte tenu des
évènements actuels voyez le reportage de
pascal golomer et alone grego comme si
de rien n'était le quartier de méa
sharim n'est qu'à quelques centaines de
mètres de la vieille ville
pourtant ici ni barrages ni forces de
l'ordre dieu nous protège distille ce
qui compte c'est de préparer souccot la
fête des cabanes comme il se doit avec
ses symboles et ses valeurs générosité
la team souffre de la contraction à
contracture l'equilibre l équilibre
cette année
l'explication tourner au quiz car le
jeune homme s'en prend à la france bien
trop complaisante selon hugues vis-à-vis
des palestiniens
la france a montré le vrai visage
qu'elle a toujours eu et aujourd'hui on
vous explique les symboles de la fête
mais on appelle aussi à tous les justes
de france de réagir et de comprendre
dans quel pays ils vivent ou marché de
marin lié aux dates ou proches
on prépare aussi la fête mais dans une
ambiance bien différente beaucoup plus
de forces de l'ordre que d'habitude
beaucoup moins de monde dans les allées
aussi commerçants et consommateurs
craignent le pire
un attentat comme celui qui a déjà tué
ici même il ya quelques années je vous
dis la vérité partout je vais je regarde
autour de moi pour voir s'il ya quelque
chose d'anormal
je ne pense qu'à ça annie elle aussi est
rentré tôt aujourd'hui pour préparer
avec ses enfants la fête à la maison
dans ce qui doit symboliser la tante de
ses ancêtres parce que c'est la
tradition est quelqu'un aujourd'hui plus
que jamais à la respecter comme
d'habitude mais bien entendu on et
passera au fond de nous mêmes loin
d'être heureux et elle le sait déjà tout
le monde quittera la table tôt ce soir
pour suivre les dernières informations à
la radio ou à la télévision
la route où nous trouvons se trouve dans
le quartier de beitounia l'ouest de
ramallah ramallah 7 au bout de cette
route à deux kilomètres mais on
distingue derrière moi déjà des imf des
habitations palestiniennes les
territoires sous l'autorité palestinien
sont bouclés fermer et l'armée
isralienne a symboliquement installé des
blocs de béton ici on ne passe pas c'est
le cas pour plus d'un million de
palestiniens dans la bande de gaza où se
trouve à l'âme seule ronde gilles
jacquier est talal abou rahmeh
la mosquée palestine de gaza est connu
pour être le fief des intégristes du
hamas et en ce vendredi décrété jour de
colère
l'imam sort bien vite du discours
religieux et aborde le politique
la glorification des martyrs et la
victoire finale voulue par al là à la
sortie de la prière les fidèles
rejoindre une manifestation unitaire
dans les rues de gaza fatah hamas jihad
unis mais les islamistes tiennent le
haut du pavé
il n'y a pas d'autre solution pour
libérer la mosquée al aqsa que le sang
tout d'un coup une fumée s'élève à
quelques centaines de mètres de là les
israéliens aurait-il attaqué commis hier
sur place c'est la panique
c'est un hôtel alto gouna qui brûle on y
servait de l'alcool les pompiers
évacuent des bonbonnes de gaz
c'est le hamas qui a mis le feu
c'est très dangereux cinq minutes plus
tard c'est un restaurant qui brûlent sur
le bord de mer hamas profitent du climat
d'unité nationale et impose sa loi à
arafat
en fin d'après-midi le djihad autres
mouvements intégristes mais faux drapeau
israélien américain est présente sur
scène ses futurs kamikazes
toute la stratégie du djihad est une
effrayante stratégie du sacrifice la
meilleure défense pour le peuple
palestinien
c'est la mort nous sommes prêts à donner
cent mille martyrs
cent mille martyrs chaque famille est
prêt à donner un marque et on s'étonne
qu'aujourd'hui encore des enfants avec
leur fronde et leurs pierres se soient
lancés à l'attaqué de l'implantation
israélienne de kfar darom au prix de 7
blessés et en direct de gaza lundi
s'élevant apparemment même si la tension
reste très vive pas d'affrontement ni
d'accident majeur aujourd'hui peut-on
dire pour autant que yasser arafat a le
contrôle en main de la situation
écoutez si on pose la question aux
collaborateurs de yasser arafat la
réponse est oui
avec tout de même un bémol on ne peut
pas dit s'il allait à l'encontre des
masses en vérité là la réponse est sans
doute plus complexes d'abord
géographiquement yasser arafat contrôle
sans doute mieux gaza où ils résident
que la cisjordanie dont il est coupé
ensuite politiquement il n'a pas le même
pouvoir naturellement sur la police
palestinienne où le fatah son propre
mouvement
car sur son opposition islamiste c'est à
dire le hamas ou le jihad
alors pour le moment disons qu'il
cherche l'unité à tout prix quitte à
libérer la des prisonniers et qu'il
avait dans ses geôles des personnes et
islamistes la stratégie est la même
c'est à dire résister faire face même si
arafat a plutôt tendance à vouloir faire
baisser la tension par exemple ce matin
en ordonnant l'arrestation des
responsables du lynchage hier de deux
soldats israéliens
mais tandis que les islamistes
naturellement une position beaucoup plus
dur le maintien de la tension à tout
prix mais si demain si demain les
stratégies diverger si par exemple
yasser arafat ouvrez des négociations
rouvrez le processus de paix alors là
c'est la question ont été catégoriques
n'obéiront pas merci adam salvan nous
repartons à jérusalem avec vous claude
sérillon vous avez à vos côtés le
principal négociateur palestinien
et sans doute autour de cette question
les efforts diplomatiques
vont-ils aboutir à cette première étape
indispensable le sommet du caire
qu'appelle de ses voeux kofi annan le
secrétaire général de l'onu
oui béatrice live arcade l'un des
principaux négociateurs palestiniens
vous êtes ministre d'arafat
alors est ce que l'on peut dire qu'il y
aura dans les 48 heures un sommet à
charm el-cheikh hockey yasser arafat
participera voilà je pense que la chose
la plus importante c'est pas de ce
septet de ce coût serait sur le
peut-être pas le processus peut être que
les américains ou d'autres vont arriver
à faire revenir les palestiniens les
israéliens ensemble sommet mais c'est
sur le terrain que les choses se passent
non plus de partenaires monsieur bara
d'asasp a choisi monsieur sharon comme
partenaire
monsieur sharon il ânonne de paix on a
parlé et des colons israéliens des
extrémistes est ce que ce sont des gens
veulent faire à fès après plus de 25 ans
de ma vie que je me consacre à la mp au
processus de paix je n'ai jamais senti
autant de confusion qu'aujourd'hui dans
mon esprit c'est une guerre de folie qui
doit s'arrêter tout de suite mais c'est
vrai qu'à vous même est ce que vous êtes
des hommes de paix lorsque des
palestiniens linge des militaires
israéliens
est-ce que vous êtes prêts que c'était
une commission d' enquête pour retrouver
les auteurs de ce lynchage non non aux
causes
bien sûr nous avons condamné ce qui va
mal n'acceptons pas cette idée de tuer
des israéliens des palestiniens
quinze officiers palestiniens ont été
blessés lors de cet incident malheureux
hier président rafat les a condamnés la
chose
il a demandé qu'une commission soit
conséquent je vous demande
je n'ai juste un terrien jeudi 105
palestiniens ont été tués assassinés
3000 ont été blessés est ce que monsieur
bara fait des enquêtes sur ces officiers
ce qui les attend juste il a sauvé sa
normale
oui donc nous ne sommes pas du tout en
train de justifier ce qui s'est passé à
ramallah chaque série 4 jusqu où
étiez-vous prêt d'arriver à un accord
lorsque ces événements ont éclaté je
sais que vous avez eu 37 rencontres avec
les israéliens qui n'avait pas réussi un
seul papier
est-ce que cet affrontement n'était pas
inévitable
est-ce que vous ne risquez pas de perdre
complètement le contrôle de vos troupes
et nos dates
affectionnant les lettres auxquelles je
pense seul journaliste j ai assisté à
des réunions jeudi 30 sept réunions avec
d'autres avec des collègues de vis-à-vis
peut-être que l'on cherche à sortir de
ce processus de la part de barack hop il
est allé voir sharon peut-être que le
prix des trop élevé et il y a des gens
tout ce qu il faut s'arrêter il faut
arrêter cette guerre de folie nous
n'avons pas de décolleté n'avons pas
d'armée l'équation la suivante du côté
israélien on tire du côté palestinien on
meurt en vain s'ils ont frappé hier nuit
jéricho il n'y avait pas de négociations
avant n'y avait rien et la plupart des
bombes ont explosé à 1100 mètres de ma
maison
merci mme haché avec à une question
chars dans la rue ce matin josaine
quelqu'un m'a arrêté mehdi je n'ai
jamais vu un tel climat de haine vous
qu'il est réduite rend plus de 30 ans
ici est-ce que vous avez déjà connu un
tel niveau de haine
non je crois que même lorsque nous avons
vécu des guerres ici que ce soit la
guerre d'octobre la guerre de kippour la
guerre au liban les incidents graves
l'intifada rarement d'abord nous
journalistes ont eu tellement de mal à
travailler sur le terrain
nous avons des bouclages beaucoup plus
difficile pour passer nous sommes
fréquemment pris entre deux feux et puis
effectivement alors que par exemple
pendant l'intifada des équipes de
télévision israéliennes pouvait
travailler assez librement secteurs
palestiniens aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup
plus difficile
il a effectivement une haine une colère
comme jamais on en a connu ici et c'est
cela qui est le plus inquiétant dans
cette phase du conflit
monsieur eric un évier vainqueurs et
vaincus évoqué lé nombre de morts parmi
plus d'une centaine de morts il ya des
arabes israéliens ils sont un million
d'arabes il serait bien qu'ils vivent en
territoire d'israël ils vivent ils y
travaillent ils sont citoyens israéliens
une famille à nazareth inconnue le pire
l'un des siens est mort c'est l'un de
ces cent ou et quelques morts
palestiniens claude sans permis
fièrement son talent et à nazareth la
famille du docteur yazbek a perdu l'un
des siens dimanche dernier selon la
tradition musulmane durant sept jours
celui qui le désirent peuvent venir
présenter ses condoléances aux proches
du défunt
issam yazbek avait 26 ans il était arabe
et citoyen d'israël dimanche dernier de
violents affrontements ont éclaté à
nazareth entre la population juive qui
vit dans la ville haute et la population
arabe qui vit au centre
deux arabes israéliens ont trouvé la
mort abattu par la police dit sami
asbeck était l'un d'entre eux son père
ne veut pas parler seul
l'umq acceptera de nous dire quelques
mots
à travers vous je voudrais lancer cet
appel au premier ministre s'il vous
plaît monsieur barack laissez nous
connaître la vérité qui a tué notre
enfant s'il vous plaît faites une
enquête officielle pour ramener le calme
à près d'un million d'arabes israéliens
vivent aujourd'hui en israël
ils représentent 20% de la population
depuis le début des affrontements presse
d'entre eux ont été tués par la police
de leur pays dans la maison voisine sont
regroupés les femmes elles non plus ne
comprennent pas aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement agisse d'une telle manière
avec les arabes israéliens
la mère du jeune garçon tué nous dira en
quelques phrases nous sommes entre les
mains
alors pourquoi ils nous traitent comme
ça ils protègent les juifs et pas nous
nous avons des papiers israël mon fils
était israël
alors pourquoi tout ça aujourd'hui ces
citoyens d'israël ont l'impression
d'être considérés comme des ennemis dans
leur propre pays et ils réclament
justice
nous sommes ici à ramallah alors que des
échanges de tirs ont lieu régulièrement
entre palestiniens et puis ça liens qui
ont posté un char non loin d'ici
ramallah qui fut le théâtre hier d'une
terrible défénestration trois militaires
israéliens ont été lynchées à mort et
cela embraser toute la région hier avec
des ripostes israéliennes
quel est l'état d'esprit de l'armée
israélienne aujourd'hui charles enderlin
nous raconte le bouclage hermétique de
bethléem c'est le colonel marcel aviv
qui en a la responsabilité
rien ne doit passer au barrage un camion
veut pénétrer dans la ville de la
nativité
mais les ordres sont les ordres
tu sais qui je suis non alors dealer
qu'il fasse demi tour et s'il te font
des problèmes tu appelle la police le
bouclage
c'est le bouclage la sécurité des
implantations juives de son secteur et
l'autre grand souci du colonel ici sur
une colline proche des frat à l'ouest de
bethléem une section est en alerte
l'autre joueur des coups de feu en
toucher ces caravanes
personne n'a été blessé mais les soldats
ont riposté et atteint 2 dea cei
hélas le colonel marcel n'a pas d'états
d'âme
toute personne armée menaçant la vie
d'israéliens civilo-militaires sur une
cible pour ses tireurs d'élite les il
raconte je veux dire qu'il ya aussi des
choses positives et j'espère que vous
allez le montrer avant-hier soir a nommé
réservistes et un civil israélien ont
pénétré par erreur en secteur autonome
ils ont été arrêtés par la police
palestinienne ils ont reçu quelques
coups rien de grave
et puis nous les ont ramenés sains et
saufs mais en leur confisquant larmes
alors là j'ai râlé mais le lendemain
quand j'ai vu le lynchage à ramallah
j'ai appelé mon homologue palestina pour
le remercier de ce comportement humain
pas comme ces animaux drama là et on a
décidé tous les deux de prendre des
mesures pour ramener le calme
et de fait un calme tendu à renier
aujourd'hui dans le secteur de bethléem
l hyper nerveux ça vous êtes parole de
monsieur barack à quelles conditions
monsieur barack ira-t-il un sommet
charm-el-cheikh avec ace arafat
monsieur brac veut tout d'abord voir la
violence et c'est dans les territoires
je crois que c'est normal
avant qu'on se met à table pour parler
il faut que arafat donne l'ordre de
cesser la violence
cela peut être difficile parce que j'ai
vu votre service maintenant lorsque
arafat libère les terroristes du hamas
et du jihad islamique et hier ce un
effet hier vous voyez déjà leurs
agissements à gaza vous voyez déjà les
terroristes kamikazes avec leurs
linceuls blancs préparant des actes de
terrorisme contre israël
monsieur arafat a vendu la situation
beaucoup plus compliquée en libérant ces
terroristes qui étaient arrêtés en cause
de leur activité contre israël
et quelle part de responsabilité vous
reconnaissez vous vous israéliens dans
ce qui vient d'arriver et bien très peu
parce que nous nous sommes défendus
parce que c'est comme mon mac monsieur
sharon rencontre monsieur laraque que
vous allez peut-être sur une alliance
moi j'étais là aux élections en 98 on
était très très loin de l'idée qu'il y
ait une puisse y avoir une alliance
entre monsieur barack et monsieur sharon
vous savez le peuple d'israël
aujourd'hui se sent menacée sur sa
propre terre nous devons au front sur
trois fronts 1 contre les palestiniens
des territoires et vous avez vu ce qui
s'est passé a ramené hier
deuxièmement contre une partie des
arabes israéliens qui se sont soulevés
et votre service n'a pas montré ce qui
s'était passé la semaine derière en
effet elle lors des émeutes des arabes
israéliens
lorsqu'ils ont coupé le pays en quatre
et on ne pouvait plus aller de tel-aviv
à la galilée et troisièmement sur le
liban sarah commence le risque balader
trois soldats alors qu'israël
aujourd'hui se sent menacé et il est
normal que quand un peuple est menacée
on se regroupe
je crois que nous avons besoin ici
d'unités en face d'eux qu'ils sont
immenses monsieur moratinos vous menez
vos nom de l'union européenne
deux patientes négociations je sais
faisait des jeunes et je crois avec
monsieur rafat aujourd'hui vous avez des
contacts avec monsieur barack qu'elle
est l'espoir
ce soir ce vendredi soir pour un sommet
prochain et pourquoi un retour un
processus de pêche quoi qu'on doit être
plus positives et plus optimistes pour
la tenue de ce sommet même si encore
l'atmosphère n'est pas tout à fait celle
que tout le monde désire
je crois que les dernières l'effort de
la communauté internationale et hier
monsieur solana
aujourd'hui à biarritz les chefs d'état
ou admis europe 1 le président chirac a
en moyenne appel d'urgence à la région
au peuple palestinien israélien aux
dirigeants israélien et palestinien pour
s'engager dans la voie de la dialogue de
la négociation la seule façon de
résoudre ce problème je crois que le
temps est venu pour arrêter la violence
pour cessez le feu pour éviter les
hostilités et pour reprendre les
négociations
je vous remercie de témoignages béatrice
voilà pour les témoignages des
reportages que nos équipes ont pu
réaliser aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ya
d'autres événements notamment hors des
frontières d'israël et de la palestine
en effet merci claude nous partons tout
de suite au liban dans ce pays qui
compte quelques 350 mille palestiniens
réfugiés
cette journée aura été marquée elle
aussi par de nombreuses manifestations
anti israéliennes alors que l'aviation
de tsahal survolait le sud du pays
simulant des raids aériens dorothée
lyrique et patrick voix pour cette
journée de la colère arabe ont assisté à
l'un de ces mouvements de protestation
et de solidarité
les jeunes palestiniens ont affublé les
pantins à l'effigié des routes baraki de
madeleine albright de croix gammées les
insultes fusent sur israël qui a aussi
bombardé hier leurs frères de palestine
ils sont plus d'un millier et la
manifestation à la couleur de la guerre
s'il nous laisse passer nous irons à la
frontière nous voulons donner notre sang
à la palestine doublons être des martyrs
on doit nous laisser passer vous
prendrez votre si c'est nécessaire ou et
je le ferai
élevé dans cette religion du martyr les
plus petits sont aussi du cortège
quant aux femmes elles battent le pavé
avec la même ardeur que leur mari ou
leur frère mais elle rêve à autre chose
qu'à la guerre vous êtes vous contre les
violences
vous allez vous rendre à la frontière
avec israël
non je crois pas mal eux veulent
affronter les soldats israéliens à coups
de pierres et de haine
mais les consignes et palestiniennes
sont stricts ne pas la laisser sortir du
camp
les camps de réfugiés sont des enclaves
palestiniennes au liban
la route qui mène à la frontière c'est
l'armée libanaise qui la comprend c'est
blindé qui n'étaient pas là hier sont
prévus pour bloquer d'éventuels
mouvements de jeunes palestiniens à
quelques centaines de mètres de la terre
israélienne
les casques bleus patrouillent quelques
mesures de sécurité renforcées pour
éviter l'embrasement au sud liban
les soldates israéliennes ont déployé
ici à la frontière avec le liban aucune
troupe particulière il faut dire qu'ils
ont diffusé un message très clair hier
soir si des manifestants palestiniens
viennent les provoquer ici avec des
pierres alors ils riposterons avec des
armes et l'armée libanaise précisément
soucieuse d'éviter tout incident a
empêché des palestiniens de se rendre
vers la frontière sud
multipliant ici et là des barrages et
des contrôles le proche orient était
dans tous les esprits au sommet de
biarritz où les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne
exhorte palestiniens israéliens à
reprendre le dialogue de toute urgence
avec cet espoir pas encore démentie d'un
très prochain se met sur la paix au
proche- rien qui pourrait se tenir
vraisemblablement dès dimanche en egypte
de kofi annan le secrétaire général de
l'onu se dit optimiste res de la réponse
d'israël qui ne fait pas encore engagé
christian mary mono l'eau si on avait la
couleur des mauvais jours
la crise du proche orient était la
principale préoccupation des 15 à
l'invitation de la présidence française
l'union européenne a lancé un appel
solennel à la cessation immédiate des
violences
même si l'europe a peu de poids dans
cette région ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la présidence les 15
monsieur pères feront tous je dis bien
tous et au delà de ce qui est possible
avec notre intelligence des choses avec
notre expérience avec notre bonne
volonté mais aussi avec notre coeur tout
ce qui peut être fait pour faciliter
l'arrêt de la violence
la reprise du dialogue et le retour à
une table qui pourrait nous reconduire
vers un accord de paix
coïncidence ou non la présence à
biarritz de l'ancien premier ministre
israélien a surpris au cours de ces
consultations shimon pérès a exprimé
l'espoir
la prochain cessez le feu mais ces
sommets est également consacrée à la
réforme des institutions
c'est à dire la repondération des voix
le vote à la majorité qualifiée la
réforme de la commission bref que des
sujets qui fâchent et pourtant il n'y a
pas eu de blocage politique aujourd'hui
et demain on veut d'être européenne
le président yougoslave costume de chat
il viendra demander de l'aide aux
européens de l'aide pour reconstruire
son pays et la démocratie non de chaque
de la crise au proche orient continue de
se propager avec ces nouveaux incidents
antisémites en france malgré l'appel au
calme répétés des différentes
communautés la nuit dernière cette
attente a bondi contre la synagogue qui
vient s'ajouter à d'autres agressions du
même type contre des lieux de culte
placés par ordre du gouvernement sous
surveillance renforcée
lionel jospin qui s'est déclaré ce soir
un dîner par ces actes odieux
valérie ermite r6 niveau beach 3 qui ont
explosé qui ont pris feu celui-là a pu
heureusement être maîtrisés à temps
si l'un des trois cocktails molotov
lancés contre cette école juive de
saint-ouen c'est aussi l'une des six
agressions contre une institution
israélites
cette nuit en france et cocktails ont
atteint que les murs de l'école mais
cela aurait pu être plus grave
à l'instar de la synagogue de bondy ou
de ce qu'il en reste
les individus y ont escaladé les grilles
cassé une vitre avant de jeter là encore
des cocktails molotov
nous sommes particulièrement indignés
est aussi en train d' une certaine
inquiétude pour la prolifération d'actes
d'hostilité à la communauté juive
une inquiétude partagée par leurs
représentants de la communauté musulmane
de bondy venu apporter son soutien le
juif est l'arabe l'autre image celle
d'une cohabitation fraternelle ont voulu
montrer le président de l'union des
étudiants juifs de france et celui des
sceaux est racisme devant un parterre de
lycéens parisiens et filles de
transposer essayer de faire venir un
conflit qui est loin nous de 4000 km le
faire venir à paris ne correspondent
absolument à rien le faire venir en
france ne correspond absolument rien
qu'est ce qu'on entend on entend dire
ici une baston dans quel but la can make
s'est fait cracher dessus
line si la dengue a brûlé là on dit sale
juif est là il ya un moment pour dire
qu'elle mais vous là ça suffit d'un
bowling mort aux juifs
de l'autre côté on finira par dire
morose rabat un appel au dialogue au
respect à la tolérance relayer toute
cette semaine un peu partout dans les
lycées français
une journée de prière pour les musulmans
dans tous les esprits des responsables
de la communauté le souci d'apaisement
qui tranchait avec la tension palpable
chez les fidèles reportage loïc de la
mornais jean marie n'est sortie de la
prière du vendredi dans cette mosquée
parisienne
la foule se rassemble les images
d'actualité comme la mort d'un enfant
palestinien où le lynchage de ramallah
ont échauffé les esprits
les journalistes on a comparé les offres
qui est un enfant et lanciers trois
soldats s'étaient soldats ils ont choisi
leur métier ils ont été tous tués ou
pour mourir et ils sont morts
c'est leur problème mais longtemps ils
sont peut-être c'était pas des soldats
ils n'avaient pas des piats il n'aurait
pas frappé
il en veut lever les mains dans le ciel
et on leur a tiré dessus comme des
lapins
on n'est pas des radars un peu plus tôt
à la mosquée d'evry
les responsables religieux s'efforcent
de calmer leurs fidèles
le recteur réputé pour sa modération
condamne les attaques contre les
synagogues et organise même une prière
des morts pour les trois soldats
israéliens lynché à ramallah la
communauté musulmane doit faire gaffe et
dont la communauté juive doit faire très
attention pour ne pas sombrer dans
l'océan de la violence et de la haine
l'appel au calme semble entendue par les
aînés mais la réaction chez les plus
jeunes suscite quelques inquiétudes
on ne sait pas comment ils réagissent
les on vous parlait de la jeunesse
notamment il de la jeunesse oui par la
journée s'ils ont un handicap ils
connaissent pas vraiment leur islam ils
entendent un petit peu à gauche et à
droite les fidèles rentrer chez eux la
tête calme mais le coeur encore bien
agitée au plan économique cette escalade
de la violence au proche orient un
sérieux impact sur le prix du baril qui
s'est à nouveau envolé une flambée des
cours attisées par le spectre d'une
éventuelle crise d'approvisionnement
jean bernard schmidt
c'est une habitude de s'agiter sur le
marché où se négocie le pétrole à
londres
aujourd'hui pourtant le calme est peu à
peu revenu après la poussée de fièvre
d'hier l'hypothèse d'un conflit
embrasant le moyen-orient a provoqué une
vive tension sur un marché du pétrole
déjà fébrile
résultat 11 % de hausse en une
demi-heure
le prix du baril déjà élevé depuis
plusieurs mois a dépassé les 37 dollars
son plus haut niveau depuis la guerre du
golfe
question d'anticipation les
professionnels craignent en effet que
les pays producteurs de pétrole ne soit
entraînée dans un conflit dur
si demain c'est la guerre ouverte les
pays arabes vont se sentir obligés de se
solidariser avec les palestiniens et
avec les arabes d'israël est l'une des
armes qui pourraient être utilisés bien
sûr ses larmes du pétrole aujourd'hui
personne ne parle embargo par contre sur
le plan politique
vous avez déjà des mouvements qui font
appel aux pays arabes pour qu'ils
utilisent l'or du pétrole larmes du
pétrole
en clair fermer les vannes
en 73 lors du premier choc pétrolier on
n'en est pas là mais redoutant une
aggravation de la situation l'union
européenne appelle pays producteurs et
consommateurs à s'entendre sur des prix
stable et raisonnable des prix qui
devraient pourtant augmenté des deux
mains à la pompe
conséquence logique de la flambée des
cours du pétrole 10 centimes de plus par
litre et les pétroliers affirment ne
répercuter qu'un tiers de l'augmentation
et la hausse des prix à la consommation
en france qui s'explique par la montée
vertigineuse du prix du pétrole 0,6 pour
cent d'augmentation pour le mois de
septembre
au total sur 12 mois selon l'insee
l'inflation de 2,2 pour cent
contrairement aux rumeurs la commission
européenne vient de donner son feu vert
à la fusion de vivendi canal+ avec le
groupe seagram
une bonne nouvelle pour jean marie
messier mais un accord sous conditions
en marge du sommet européen qui se tient
à biarritz eu des affrontements se sont
produits cet après midi entre jeunes
indépendantistes basques et forces de
l'ordre lors de cette marche partie de
bayonne et qui tentaient de se rendre
dans le centre de biarritz là même où se
tient jusqu'à demain à la réunion des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement de
l'union européenne parce qu'elle d'où
ces banques parce quelqu'un en route
pour biarritz les manifestants
nationalistes avaient annoncé dès hier
leur intention de ne plus rester
cantonné à bayonne il est 16 heures les
gendarmes mobiles par la route en lot
le face à face va durer à peine quelques
secondes
quelques slogans l'ehpad insultes vingt
mètres derrière les leaders politiques
qui ne vont pas tarder à s'effacer
les manifestants cash calmement leur
visage et ramassent des pierres
et voici la suite deux vagues de
caillassage de 15 secondes chacune et
les manifestants décrochent avant d'être
atteint par les grenades lacrymogènes
leur repli est tout aussi organisés il
s'agit de protéger la retraite en créant
des obstacles sans omettre bien sûr de
s'en prendre aux policiers qui jusque là
s'était fait très discret celui ci elle
n'est cassé son collègue blessé au bras
et alors nombreux nous lyncher comme ça
c'est vraiment ludique au
qu'est ce que nous appelons à mettre les
nationalistes eux déplorent une dizaine
de blessés
au pays basque espagnol on est habitué à
ce type d'action très organisés mais
côté français on n'en avait pas vu
depuis les années 80 en fait l'immense
majorité des manifestants d'aujourd'hui
sont venues d'espagne
ils sont retournés en moins d'une heure
dans leur fief du petit bayonne
désormais séparée du reste de la ville
par les forces de l'ordre qui devrait
rester là une partie de la nuit
le prix nobel de la paix attribué
aujourd'hui au président sud-coréen kim
jong-il était donné favori son action en
faveur de la réconciliation des deux
pays ennemis aura séduit le comité
norvégien
bernard lebrun tendu mais souriant kim
dae-jung pour cet instant historique
les deux présidents réunie du sud et du
nord
après trois ans de conflit sanglant et
des décennies de guerres froid pour voir
cette image les 68 millions de coréens
auront attendu cinquante ans et c'est
ainsi que cette rencontre donna lieu au
miracle de sydney la diplomatie par le
sport et pour la toute première fois
l'apparition publique est peut être
prématuré de la bannière d'une corée
réunifiée suivi des athlètes du sud et
guillaume 12 événements ont permis ce
rapprochement tant attendu pour la
désescalade militaire dans la région
tout d'abord l'élection présidentielle
du très démocratique quine des jo après
40 ans d'opposition
cet ancien dissident qui a connu la
prison mettait fin des années de
dictature
second événement le régime de pyongyang
du nord ultranationaliste connaît alors
une grave crise économique provoquant
une famine d'un autre temps à 75 ans le
président sud-coréen initiateurs il est
vrai de cette incroyable réconciliation
ignore tout pour l'instant de la
réaction de son homologue l'autre king
kim jong il à son prix ne risque-t-il
pas de remettre en cause ce fragile
équilibre
nouvelle non la paix n'est jamais
acquise il y a 6 ans un palestinien et
deux israéliens a été mobilisée pour
avoir inventé un processus de paix
aujourd'hui pour le mois moribond en
politique l'exclusion hier soir et sans
grand suspense de jean tiberi du rpr le
maire de paray notre invité il nous dira
dans un instant dans quel état d'esprit
ils abordent les jours et les mois à
venir mais heureusement d'abord sur
cette soirée de la disgrâce
laura kim cyril paquet ce matin jean
tiberi avait un peu la gueule de bois
la veille en l'excluant le rpr a tiré un
trait sur 50 ans d'engagement gaulliste
pour sanctionner sont en tête
ce sont des méthodes qui date d'un autre
siècle et qui ne sont plus adaptées à la
démocratie
hier soir le maire est venu jouer
l'avocat de sa propre cause devant ses
compagnons dans son sillage une
indescriptible bousculade
pourtant le résultat est attendu et même
connu depuis plusieurs jours avant même
le vote des délégués nicole cathala la
présidente du rpr parisien démentira
plus de formes de trucage le huis clos
politico dramatique dure plus de deux
heures
à l'intérieur on dit l'ambiance
électrique à l'extérieur les supporters
tibet rist laisse éclater leur rancoeur
à leur sortie des séguiniste ne cachent
pas leur soulagement d'un homme
produire la béchère jean tiberi devenu
pestiférés du rpr a été exclu par une
très large majorité très affecté il
parle d'un climat haineux ignoble
surtout il confirme sa détermination à
ce que du fond de mon coeur joli ce soir
tristesse colère et détermination c'est
sans doute une des plus mauvaises
soirées que j'ai passé dans dix jours
les instances nationales du rpr
valideront la sanction jean tiberi
candidats inflexible dire à jacques
chirac son amertume
depuis hier soir le maire de paris et
pour de bon entré en dissidence sont
fédérées bon soir soit 24 heures après
donc votre exclusion
dans quel état d'esprit êtes vous ce
soir je me sentais très ému en envoyant
ses images sur portageo certaines ont
gelé indiqué un des moments les plus
difficiles depuis des années je milite
je n'ai jamais connu une telle situation
et je crois que le mouvement n'en a
jamais connue tout ça est vraiment très
triste et inacceptable
est-ce que ce soir vous diriez vous êtes
un peu comme un animal blessé prêts à
charger pour se venger elle mettait un
animal blessé non je ne bouge pas je me
bats je ne me suis jamais venger jeu je
considère que l'attitude de mes amis
entre guillemets et inacceptable ils se
sont mal comportés à mon endroit envers
un vieux gaulliste mais moi je veux me
battre je suis aussi mécontent parce que
pourquoi parce qu'on a refusé de me
donner l'investiture sans entendre et
sans me donner des spectacles est
hébergée à penser qu'une chose que vous
avez dit apparemment vous n'avez pas été
entendu c'est vrai c'est maintenant que
les choses étaient réglées n'avance pas
alors je ne sais pas si jacques chirac
vous entendra sur ce point vous avez dit
donc votre souhait de le rencontrer très
prochainement qu'elle ait voulu lui dire
dans quel état d'esprit allez-vous que
d'être président de la république est au
dessus des querelles en ce qui concerne
les mouvements politiques et notamment
pour les élections municipales il me l'a
dit il l'a dit publiquement mais là il
ya une étape qui a été franchie il ya eu
des attaques de mes amis injustes
inacceptables
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir et on a
refusé de donner l'investiture dans des
conditions anti démocratique et là on a
franchi l'étape on mise plus du
mouvement dans lequel travaillent depuis
des décennies là c'est une étape alors
je veux dire au président parce que
c'est le chef de l'état c'est mon ami il
a été maire de paris président du
rassemblement ce que je
sans sur le plan de l'émotion sur le
plan politique et je veux lui faire part
de tout ça en lui disant que c'est
inacceptable et j'écouterais c'est qu'il
lui demanderait également s'il a une par
une part de responsabilité dans votre ex
us j'évoquerai tous les problèmes
avaient compris ses villas je ne veux
pas dire ce soir ce que je vais dire au
président la règle mais je viens vous
dire comme l'essentiel de ce que je veux
lui dire mais est ce que vous pensez qu
en effet jacques chirac peut avoir eu
d'une certaine façon une influence une
part même si en effet une ehpad n'est
plus chef du rpr il m'a dit qu'il n'a
jamais participé à ça donc je le crois
qu est ce que c est un ami il est
évident qu'une partie de l'entourage a
certainement joué un jeu négatif dans
tout cela
elle ça ça n'est pas acceptable aussi
alors on va être essayé d'être très
concrets pour savoir quel est votre de
venir parce que vous avez à devenir
alors vous avez donc toujours dit que
les municipales vous feriez la bataille
de paris vous allez donc continuer alors
moi je vous livre un sondage qui est
paru aujourd'hui
selon la sofres bertrand delanoë donc il
candidat de gauche l'emporterait dans
tous les cas de figure 51 % au second
tour contre philippe seguin et dans le
cas d'une triangulaire c'est à dire dans
le cas où vous maintiendrez et c'est
peut-être une probabilité vous auriez
13% philippe seguin 39 et bertrand
delanoë donc gagnerait devant vous 2 à
48% alors est ce que vous pensez qu'avec
ses résultats et ses indications ça vous
fait changer d'avis l'idée de ne pas
tirer contre votre propre camp je veux
faire gagner mon camp
ce sont les méthodes les décisions de
l'appareil du rpr actuelle vous dis
existerait qui ont abouti à cette
situation
je constate qu'ils ont choisi philippe
séguin sans donner de motifs met en
effet en tant que c'est le meilleur
candidat
or on voit bien que c'est pas un bon
candidat mais vincent parler les
chiffres
il faut vous allez vous désister
attendez-vous j'ai dit qu'au premier
tour c'est les parisiens qui trancheront
mais aussi je suis en tête
je demande aux africains de faire
alliance avec moi dans l'esprit et la
lettre de la loi mais si je suis en 2d
je demande la réciprocité et je ferais
la même chose vous me tiendrais cela
s'est il est vrai qu avec 13% des voix
peut-être dix agents tournant j'ai dit
si je suis en tête je demande à philippe
seguin de se retirer pour moi on verra
relais les sondages évolué voulait que
le gaz et vous pouvez être entamée bien
entendu c'est ma voulons
saleh il ya quelques mois si vous
n'achetez mais oui ça sent mauvais
j'avais 3 4 5 % aujourd'hui ses 10 14%
il évolue considérable en si vous n'êtes
pas en tête vous restez au second tour
non si je suis pas en tête je proposerai
dans les deux cas que je sois en tête ou
pas en tête à philippe seguin accord que
celui qui sera en tête acceptent de
recevoir l'eau c'est ça la démocratie
je veux faire respecter le suffrage des
parisiennes et des parisiens les
combines les combinaisons des partis
politiques
ça n'intéresse pas les parisiens moi je
veux travailler pour paris et les
parisiens merci monsieur jean tiberi
d'avoir donc répondu à nos questions
la suite des collections printemps-été
2001 les modèles saint laurent réalisé
pour la première fois par un nouveau
styliste tom ford qui présente donc ce
soir sa collection
voici les premières images de ses
vêtements qu'ils continueront de porter
donc la marque saint laurent
la 12e édition de lire en fête cette
manifestation nationale qui se déroulera
à partir d'aujourd'hui tout le week end
au programme la lecture célébrée par des
anonymes ou des comédiens comme à
marseille où ils nous incitent à la
lecture dans les autobus et le métro de
la ville daniel wolfromm philippe
luthier spectacle inhabituel dans le
métro à marseille
le voyageur perspicace y décèlera des
textes de jacques prévert ou de raymond
queneau
eux ce sont des comédiens professionnels
depuis une semaine
il invite les passagers à la lecture en
tentant de les associer à leur jeu merci
non me frappe à nouveau sur les pôles
importants
c'est insupportable je remarquai dans
cet autobus
c'est porter un chapeau moudre
soudain les contribuables elle des
pelles un contribuable de boîte un même
exercice de style en surface sur la
canebière près du vieux port et
voyageurs nous regardent avec le regard
indifférent des champions n'ont plus
d'autre at on entendu je me réveille et
je vois un petit homme debout en blouse
blanche vous aimez way avec à une fraise
mécanique à la main ouais mais que
lisent donc les marseillais
j'ai toujours un livre en cours on à
dire ce jour un livre en cours mais je
mets le temps quand les romains patron
non non non pas trop on voyait jeux pas
trop le temps ouais avec deux enfants
les mener à l'école et le la vie
quotidienne non j'ai pas le temps de
dire vous avez le temps de lire quand
même chose combien de temps consacré à
la lecture
la manifestation organisée par les
oeuvres laïques s'intitule la lecture
nous transporte au propre comme au
figuré
la femme que j'aime
on vient ainsi se termine ce journal je
rappelle la principale information en
israël la tension reste extrêmement vive
la ville de jérusalem pour ce vendredi
de prières sous très haute sécurité un
calme relatif malgré tout dans les
territoires après quinze jours de
violences extrêmes l'espoir d'un sommet
au caire peut-être pour dimanche ce
qu'envisage kofi annan reste qu'israël
n'a pas donné sa réponse
et j'apprends à l'instant que le premier
ministre israélien ehud barak et
considère que les états unis allaient
annoncer qu'il n'y aurait pas de sommet
au moyen-orient la météo dans un instant
avec nathalie rihouet puis le poids
route valérie maurice suivi de la série
policière pj le dernier journal vous
sera présentée par laurence piquet
demain secteur dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac recevra henri salvador
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain à 13h merci de votre
attention
excellente fin de soirée tous